once dubbed the savior of steel
now fighting to save his steel empire
it's crunch time for sanjiv gupta and
his proud but beleaguered liberty steel
as foundry's life follow fundings being
frantically sought
liberty's key lender green cell capital
collapsed last month
leaving a black hole to fill and 3 000
jobs in the balance
a government bailout was requested and
denied the firm's structure
apparently too opaque but gupta has come
out fighting
and insists he has a plan we're not
looking for any villa
we have a profitable business globally
which will be refinanced
in the short term we have some working
capital issues caused by the
noise but we're not we're not ready for
anybody we're basically doing self-help
but ultimately your workers may end up
paying may they not
for those early decisions the early
opacity of your system and the decision
to go with greenself
none of my steel plants would exist
today if it had not been for our
our effort and my work has supported me
completely i will not give up on you
under my watch none of my steel plants
will close i promise
it's a big promise especially as some
greens held investors have already
launched legal action
to wind up part of the business all this
used to be
steel works in stocksbridge ian's
families watched this industry decline
his father and his grandfather worked
here before him he wants to believe
but he's worried it's not what you do
it's who you are i support rotherham
united
we're fighting relegation but one
victory
and that gives you hope and this is what
what it is it's a bit of hope for us
saying he's not going to clause any
plans and we've all got to take his word
for it but that doesn't necessarily mean
that
nobody will lose their jobs what the
government does now is a big challenge
and there are no easy options
it's clearly reluctant to commit
taxpayers money to bailing out liberty
steel
as it is it could wait for it to go bust
and then step in
or it could do nothing if no private
finance could be found
it will mean the plants and the jobs
would go
the last option feels unlikely many of
these plants are in brexit voting former
labor heartlands
the industry's iconography not lost on
the prime minister
the wind farms the the high-speed
railway the the nuclear power stations
the the beaching reversals at wedding
all those things that were they all
involved steel it would be
crazy if we were not to use this this
post-brexit moment
to not to use the the the flexibility we
have
to to buy british steel so that's what
we want to do it may well fall to him
lack of long-term investments left the
industry hollowed
and buyers reluctant while a solution is
sought
workers can only watch and wait helen
and smith sky news in stocksbridge